It's almost time to hit the road,
but before we do it's time for, of all shows, the Doggy Bag.
(dog barking)
That's right.
We like to leave you with a little something to go.
There he goes.
And we can't talk pets without talking
about my other burning passions.
(spray bottle squirting)
Sorry, Ross. Stain removal.
(Ross laughing)
So sorry. But it smells good though.
It smells so good.
Yeah, sorry. I didn't mean to squeeze it on you.
Okay, all pet owners now,
our fury family members that we love,
like to leave us little surprises to find later.
And this is where this comes in.
This is Angry Orange Pet Odor Eliminator Spray,
and it smells so good.
It's an enzymatic cleanser that works on fabrics
and hard surfaces, you name it.
And it's totally non-toxic for kids and pets,
which is so great.
And it smells like fresh oranges, okay?
And my dogs are getting up there in age.
Celina has diabetes.
She's got a little, she's had a few accidents.
I'll just say that. I'd rather smell this, you know?
Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
I just got brand new carpet the other day
and I was so proud.
And one of the dogs just peed all over it.
Aw!
And I was just like, "Not even a day!"
"Not one day god damn day!"
(Ross laughing)
But I love them.
I know. So much.
Anyway. Thank you so much.
To all the guests in the audience, home and on the go,
we're so honored that you take the time to spend it with us.
This is all for you and about you.
Have a wonderful day and we hope we get to see you soon.
(upbeat music)